June 13 2014
started as a routine Friday in
Redemption Hospital in Monrovia the
capital of Liberia redemption is the
largest free Public Health Hospital in
the city we are called upon to serve
hundreds of thousands of people in the
best of times that puts a strain on our
resources monthly supplies run out
within weeks and patients of our beds
will be seated in chairs that summer we
had a nurse who had been sick for a
while sick enough to be admitted in our
Hospital but our treatment didn't seem
to be helping her her symptoms were
getting worse diarrhea severe abdominal
pain fever and weakness on that
particular Friday she developed severe
respiratory distress and her eyes were
menacingly red one of my fellow doctors
a general surgeon became suspicious of
her condition he said her symptoms were
suggestive of Ebola we kept a close
watch on her we tried to help her we
were treating her for malaria typhoid
and gastroenteritis we didn't know it
but by then it was too late
the next morning I walk in to check on
my patient I could tell by the look on
her eyes that she was filled with fear I
gave her a reassurance but shortly after
she died of Ebola for me what there was
very personal but this was just the
beginning a virtual biological bomb had
exploded but the war spread faster than
the virus and panic spread across the
hospital all the patients ran away then
all the nurses and doctors ran away this
was the beginning of our medical tsunami
the devastating Ebola virus that left an
indelible scar in our country's history
I was not trained for this I had just
graduated from medical school two years
before at this time my total knowledge
about Ebola came from a wound
article I had read in medical school I
perceived the disease as so dangerous
there's one page in essence she had
convinced me to run out of the hospital
- the moment I heard of a case of Ebola
but when it finally happened I stayed on
and decided to help and so that several
other brave healthcare professionals but
we would pay a heavy price many persons
and health professionals have become
high-risk contacts this actual admit 21
days counting to potentially disease or
death our health systems were fragile
our health workers lack the skills and
treating so you know weeks and months
that followed health workers were
disproportionately affected by the Ebola
virus disease more than 400 nurses
doctors and other health professionals
became infected unfortunately my friend
the general surgeon who correctly
identified the symptoms in that first
case became one of the casualties on
July 27 the President of Liberia imposed
quarantine on the worst affected areas
she closed all the schools and
universities and shut down many public
events four days later the United States
peace cops pulled out of Liberia Sierra
Leone and Guinea due to Ebola in August
six weeks after the nurse died hundreds
of people were dying of disease each
week people were dying in the street
over the months that followed was Africa
will lost thousands of people to Ebola
virus disease in August I joined a team
to set up the Ebola treatment unit at
JFK Hospital in Monrovia I was charged
with running the second Ebola treatment
unit in the city our unit provided hope
for thousands of patients families and
communities I not only provide care I
came face-to-face with Ebola living
everyday asahara's Ebola virus disease
contact during the worst of the outbreak
was one of my worst experiences I
started counting 21 days ever
day I live every moment anticipating the
onset of symptoms of the disease I
measured my body temperature several
times I showered with chlorinated water
more concentrated and actually
recommended a chlorine it at my phones
my pens my hands my car my clothes
became bleached those days you were
alone people were so afraid of touching
anybody
everyone's was counted as a potential
contact touching will make them sick
I was stigmatized but if that was what
it was for me
who was symptom-free imagine what it was
for someone who actually has symptoms
someone who had Ebola we learned that to
treat Ebola successfully we had to
suspend some of the normal rules of
society our president declared a state
of emergency in August and suspended
certain rights and the National Police
even supported our work during the Ebola
response in Feb 2015 came in for
isolation in our bola isolation unit
they were also known as the VIP boys of
Monrovia terrified small-time drug
addicts whose presence could instill
tremendous amount of fear or door they
could not legally carry guns they
underwent quarantine for 21 days in our
unit and was not arrested we told the
police if you arrest them here they will
stop coming they won't get treated and
the boulevards will continue to spread
the police agreed and we were able to
treat the VRP boys and they did not have
to worry about being arrested why in the
unit over the cause of the outbreak West
Africa had almost 29 thousand cases more
than 11,000 people died and that
included twelve of my fine colleagues at
John F Kennedy hospital in Monrovia
in June 2016 exactly 23 months after my
first Ebola patient died
Liberia declared its Ebola outbreak
ended we thought that was the outbreak
ended so did the problems we hope that
life will go back to normal today there
are more than 17,000 survivors in West
Africa people who actually had Ebola
virus disease lived through it and
survived we counted the survival rate as
a success the end of suffering for the
patient and fulfilling joyful families
every discharged from the unit was a
moment of jubilation at least so we
thought the best description of the
moment of discharge and a rare glimpse
into the moment that defines our life
post Ebola was vividly expressed in the
words of my best friend and fellow dr.
Philip Ireland in an interview of the
times he said at the time of his release
there were a lot of people there from
JFK Hospital my family my elder brother
my wife was there a lot of other doctors
were there too and members of the media
were there and I felt like Nelson
Mandela it felt like a long walk to
freedom and I walk and raise my hands to
the heaven thanking God for saving my
life and Phillips said then I saw
something else there were a lot of
crying people people happy to see me but
when I got close to anybody
they backed away for many Ebola
survivors society still seems to be
backing away even as they struggle to
lead a normal life for these survivors
life can be compared to another health
emergency
Demi suffered debilitating joint and
body pain the suffering gradually decays
over time for most however many continue
to bear intermittent pain some survivors
are blind others have neurological
disabilities some survivors experience
stigmatization every day in many ways a
lot of children high offense some
survivors experience post-traumatic
stress disorder and some survivors like
opportunity for education
even families can be split apart by fear
of Ebola - there's no definitive cue for
transmitting Ebola virus to sex however
there are successful interventions for
prevention we have worked hard on semen
testing behavioral counseling safe sex
promotion and research for the past year
there have been no cases of sexual
transmission but some mill survivors
have lost their spouses out of fear will
be infected with Ebola that's how
families are torn apart another
tremendous challenge for Ebola survivors
is obtaining adequate health care in
theory
Liberia's public health services are
free of charge in practice our health
system locked the funding and capacity
to expand care to all at the point of
need many survivors have waited many
most undergo surgery to heal they're
blinding cataracts whew how to relive
the traumatic experience when her blood
was retested for a bullet at a point of
admission some survivors experience
delayed a deferred admission due to
limited bear capacity no better vailable
for one more patient this is neither
national policy no official con dude but
many people are still afraid of the
sporadic resurgence of Ebola virus the
results can be tragic I have seen
Beatrice in Ebola survivor clinic
several times now she's 26 years old
many of her family members became
infected
she luckily survived but since that day
in 2014 she was discharged - caring
health workers her life has never been
the same she became blind as a result of
Ebola in 2014 the baby of a dear friend
of mine was only two months old when
both parents and child were admitted in
an Ebola treatment unit in Monrovia
luckily they survived my friend's baby
is almost three years old now but cannot
stand cannot walk he cannot speak he has
failure to thrive there are many more
hidden experiences and many stories are
yet untold
the survivors of Ebola deserves our
attention and support the only way we
can defeat this pandemic is when we
ensure that we win this final battle our
best opportunities to ensure that every
survivor we sees adequate care at the
point of need without any form of stigma
and had no cost to them personally
how can a society consider itself healed
when a person's entire identity is
defined by the fact that they recovered
from Ebola she were previous disease
that a person no longer has become the
sum total of the identity the
identifiers in the passport that it
turns you from traveling to seek medical
care abroad simply the ID that denies
you health care or prevents you from
having a relationship with your spouse
or denies your family or friend or whom
or prevents you from carrying on your
normal job so you can put food on the
table or have a roof over your family's
head what is the meaning of the right to
life when our life is clouded by stigma
and barriers that filled our stigma
until we have much better answers to
those questions in West Africa our work
is not over yet Liberians
are resilient people and we know how to
rise to a challenge even a devastating
one my best memories of the outbreak
centered on those many people who
survived the disease but I cannot forget
the hard-working nurses doctors
volunteers and staff who risked their
own safety in service of humanity and
some even losing their lives in the
process
during the worst of the contagion one
thing cap was making those perilous
delayed journeys into the boulevards we
had a passion to save life but I afraid
during a bola outbreak of course I was
but for me the opportunity to protect
our global health security and keep
communities safe at home and
Brod was an honor so as the dangers
became greater our humanity became
stronger we faced our fears the global
health community working together
defeated Ebola and that that is how I
know that we can defeat Earth's
aftermath in our hearts in our minds and
in our communities thank you
[Applause]
[Music]